vuelve la actividad a los puertos
ucranianos en medio de una jornada
movida los siete barcos partieron de los
muelles ubicados en el mar Negro
transportando al menos 290.000 toneladas
de productos agrícolas el movimiento se
sucede Un día después de la
reincorporación rusa al acuerdo de
granos sin embargo
Moscú aseguró que esto no es una
garantía para renovar su permanencia En
el pacto a partir del próximo 19 de
noviembre
ciertamente la discusión sobre la
prolongación del acuerdo de granos debe
continuar el periodo oficial aún no se
ha agotado ayer escucharon la
declaración del presidente pero para el
19 de noviembre debemos proporcionar una
evaluación general de la efectividad de
la implementación del acuerdo y cómo Se
realizaron los parámetros del trato
antes de decidir si continuamos
Mientras tanto en gerson el subdirector
de la Administración civil local hizo un
llamado a los residentes de la urbe a
huir para salvar sus vidas en el
contexto de una contraofensiva ucraniana
que tiene a las tropas invasoras en una
posición defensiva muchas en este
momento estamos en las calles de gerson
y como pueden ver hay mucha gente en la
ciudad les pido amablemente con todo lo
que va a pasar y las decisiones
difíciles que se van a tomar protejan
sus vidas
otros de los hechos que marcaron la
jornada fue la desconexión de la planta
nuclear de Sa polilla de la red
eléctrica nacional lo que puede
imposibilitar el funcionamiento óptimo
de sus generadores y el intercambio de
un centenar de prisioneros de las partes
en conflicto